I look at the past cycles of these growths, these S-curves forming.
It has determined so much of what we are, who we are, what we are after.
Growth is about everything.
Bacteria and babies.
Economies and empires.
Growth of everything.
And what's fascinating is to look at these S-curves forming one after another...
...in this technical innovation side.
That's always the rule, you know.
They're on this ascending stage.
People say, "Oh, wow!" you know?
And eventually, everything forms there.
Now, we're on these plateaus...
In many ways, yeah.
Even the speed one, we had the supersonic transport.
Today's planes don't fly any faster than Boeing 707.
It's about 900 kilometers per hour.
So, we've been on the plateau since 1958, indeed.
Which, of course, shows what we have known for ages, and what economists refuse to accept...
...that there cannot be indeterminate growth on a finite planet.
But, you know, there is some efficiency.
Lots of efficiency.
Actually, these planes are 70 percent more efficient per passenger-kilometer,...
...so this is underappreciated.
The speed is the same but 70 percent less energy per passenger-kilometer.
Amazing.
So, it's a fascinating examination of all these functions and conditions...
...and preconditions and consequences of growth.